bonjour peine maximum pour le docteur
garetta le principal responsable de l
affaire du sang contaminé par le virus
du sida est condamné à quatre ans de
prison ferme et 500 mille francs
d'amendé
verdict rendu ce matin un mandat d'arrêt
a été lancé contre garreta il
n'assistait pas à l'audience il est aux
états unis peine moins lourde pour deux
autres accusés le docteur nene terre est
le seul à être relaxé le jugement rendu
dans une affaire aussi terrible que
celle là ne pouvaient pourtant
satisfaire personne clément weill-raynal
quatre ans de prison ferme cinq cent
mille francs d'amendé contre michel
garretta aujourd'hui aux états unis
mandat d'arrêt délivré à l'audience
en infligeant la peine maximum à
l'ancien patron du cnts le tribunal a
bien voulu montrer qu'il n'accordait
aucune circonstance atténuante à celui
qu'il considère comme le responsable du
drame des hémophiles michel garretta
souligne le jugement était
incontestablement l'inspirateur et le
maître d'oeuvre de la politique du cnt m
si certains des hémophiles se félicitait
ce matin à la sortie de la salle
d'audience de voir la culpabilité des
médecins reconnus beaucoup demeurait
amer ce qui est remarquable dans ce
jugement c'est d'abord l'écroulement de
la défense
elle a prétendu depuis des années qu'il
s'agissait d'un accident thérapeutique
il ne s'agit pas d'un accident
thérapeutique mais bien de faits qui ont
été provoqués
siham ans par un certain nombre de
personnes la deuxième chose que je
remarque c'est que le docteur alain qui
était médecin prescripteur est condamné
à deux ans d'emprisonnement ferme
il n'est pas arrêté à l'audience le
docteur garetta qui est condamné à 4 ans
d'emprisonnement ferme est en fuite à
l'étranger
je crois qu'on laisse le temps à
monsieur alain de partir également et ça
je trouve ça lamentable et je trouve que
c'est un manque de respect vis-à-vis des
victimes
le verdict d'aujourd'hui c'est un
verdict rendu dans un tribunal
correctionnel pour des gens qui méritent
les assises
donc les peines réclamées sont
qu'illusoire
quand on assassine des gens c'est on ne
peut pas s'en tirer avec deux ans de
prison avec quatre ans de prison
c'est illusoire je reporte plainte pour
empoisonnement je laisse pas là c'est
mon mari l'aurait pas laissé là donc je
continue la lutte deux ans avec sursis
pour alain s'est passé quel est votre
sentiment et bas que ya pas de justice
que les morts en fin de compte on en a
rien à faire il n'y a que l'argent qui
compte
réactions des avocats de michel garretta
nous n'avons pas réussi à nous faire
entendre le jugement est l'aboutissement
de mois et de mois de pression que ce
soit du pouvoir politique de
de la presse des victimes certaines
légitimes et la plupart non et qui rend
très très inquiet sur les possibilités
de se faire juger normalement et
sereinement dans ce pays et dans une
affaire comme celle là il fallait une
tête
il fallait lyncher quelqu'un on va
jusqu'au bout ont fait le grand jeu
puisque le mandat de dépôt constitue
évidemment l'aboutissement de cette
logique restait ce matin au moment du
verdict une question michel garretta se
présentera-t-il pour être incarcérés